Okay, erst dachte ich:
Das ist total bescheuert.
Dann dachte ich:
Was für ein Drama.
Dann stellte sich heraus,
dass das total interessant ist.
Jetzt gibt's ein Video dazu.
Fangen wir damit an: Von Meghan
Markle bis Kim Kardashian,
welche Promis haben
die vertrauenswürdigsten Gesichter?
Nicht anhand von Umfragen, sondern
laut eines Computeralgorithmus.
Turns out, Kim Kardashian hat
mit einem Score von 92 Prozent
das vertrauenswürdigste Gesicht.
"The Sun",
ein britisches Boulevardblatt,
da steht öfter mal Unsinn drin.
Was sind diese 92 Prozent überhaupt?
Was sind 100 Prozent?
Aber die Wissenschaftler,
die zitiert werden,
haben tatsächlich ganz frisch
eine Studie veröffentlicht,
die sich um ein Machine-Learning-
Vertrauenswürdigkeitometer dreht.
War das ein Drama in meiner
Science-Nerd-Twitter-Bubble.
Nachdem der Chef-Wissenschaftler
dieser Studie
die Ergebnisse
auf Twitter vorstellte,
gab es so viele negative Reaktionen,
dass er seinen Twitter-Account
zwischenzeitlich löschte.
Was genau an dieser Studie
so problematisch war,
und was unser Gesicht über
unsere Vertrauenswürdigkeit verrät,
das klären wir jetzt.
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich.
Schauen wir doch genauer
auf dieses Science-Twitter-Drama.
Womit hatten so viele ein Problem?
Viele warfen
den Wissenschaftlern vor,
mit ihrem Algorithmus
Phrenologie zu betreiben.
Nein!
Kein seriöser Wissenschaftler möchte
sich Phrenologie vorwerfen lassen.
Was ist Phrenologie?
Springen wir mal in der Geschichte zu
den Anfängen der modernen Neurologie.
Während heute klar ist,
dass das Gehirn der Ort
unseres Bewusstseins, unserer
Fähigkeiten, Eigenschaften ist,
hatte man im 18. Jahrhundert nur
eine sehr vage Vorstellung davon.
Man hat etwa beobachtet,
dass bestimmte Verletzungen
am Hinterkopf dazu führen können,
dass die Menschen erblinden,
obwohl die Augen an sich
noch völlig in Ordnung waren.
Solche Dinge,
ließen die Ärzte damals vermuten,
dass das Gehirn eben Ort
von Sinnen und Persönlichkeit ist,
und dass bestimmte Hirnregionen für
bestimmte Funktionen zuständig sind.
Der Arzt Franz Joseph Gall befasste
sich besonders intensiv damit.
Fun tickt - Gall stammt
aus der nähe von Pforzheim.
Wie unser neues maiLab-Mitglied Jens.
Gall ordnete
verschiedenen Hirnregionen
verschiedene
Persönlichkeitseigenschaften zu.
Von Mut bis zu Farbensinn.
Solche Darstellungen
kennt ihr vielleicht.
Das ist sehr spannend, denn damals
gab es noch keine modernen Methoden,
wie MRT- oder CT-Scans,
um Gehirne zu untersuchen.
Wie hat Gall also
die verschiedenen Regionen ermittelt?
Mit einer Methode, die heute
auch noch häufig verwendet wird:
Sich Sachen einfach ausdenken.
Das war fies, weil übertrieben,
Aber er hätte es sich
genauso gut ausdenken können.
Gall kam auf seine Theorie,
indem er die Schädelformen
ganz vieler verschiedener Menschen
untersuchte, um diese dann
mit deren Persönlichkeits-
eigenschaften zu verbinden.
Er war etwa davon überzeugt,
dass witzigere Menschen
stärker ausgeprägtere ...
so Stirnhöcker haben,
als weniger witzige Menschen.
Denn seine Theorie war,
dass die Hirnregion,
die für Witz zuständig ist,
hier vorne liegt,
die dann bei witzigen Menschen
stärker ausgeprägt ist.
Und damit deren Schädel
auch mehr nach außen gestülpt ist.
Ich hab eher wenig Witz.
Die Idee,
die Persönlichkeit eines Menschen
anhand der Kopf- oder Gesichtsform
ablesen zu wollen, ist nicht neu.
Die gab's schon lange vor Gall,
bekannt als:
Aber durch Gall
hatten Physiognomik-Fans
dann plötzlich die Möglichkeit,
ihrer Idee eine vermeintlich
wissenschaftliche Basis zugeben.
Denn Gall soll wie verrückt
Daten gesammelt haben.
Er sammelte menschliche
und tierische Schädel,
Büsten von berühmten oder
berüchtigten Persönlichkeiten,
las Tausende von Biografien,
untersuchte Totenmasken.
Doch bei allem Eifer war seine
Methode nicht sehr wissenschaftlich.
Denn wenn man will, findet man leicht
Zusammenhänge, wo keine sind.
Diese zwei Leute waren gemein zu mir,
und sie haben schmale Gesichter.
Das ist kein Zufall.
Hat man diese Verbindung
erst mal im Kopf,
greift der:
Wenn ich davon überzeugt bin,
dass Menschen
mit schmalem Gesicht gemein sind,
dann fällt mir
diese Verbindung eher auf.
Wenn ich jemanden treffe,
der ein schmales Gesicht hat,
aber doch nicht gemein ist,
fällt mir das nicht auf,
ich tu's als Zufall ab oder rede
mir ein: So nett war die auch nicht.
Doch legte Gall einen Grundstein
für die moderne Neurologie.
Denn er hatte grundsätzlich recht,
dass verschiedene Eigenschaften in
bestimmen Hirnregionen verortet sind.
Mit modernen Labormethoden
kann man das heute bestätigen.
Etwa liegt das wichtigste Zentrum
der Sprachproduktion
im Broca-Areal, auf der
linken Seite des Frontallappens.
Wird diese Hirnregion beschädigt,
durch einen Schlaganfall,
kann man nicht mehr sprechen,
aber Sprache meistens noch verstehen.
Allerdings erfüllt ein Hirnareal
oft viele Funktionen gleichzeitig.
Die Amygdala
ist unter anderem zuständig
für emotionales Lernen
und Gedächtnis,
Verarbeitung von
Belohnung und Strafe
und die Einschätzung, ob wir
ein Gesicht vertrauenswürdig finden.
Außerdem beruhen viele Eigenschaften
auf dem Zusammenspiel
mehrerer Hirnregionen.
Während Gall dem Kunstsinn
eine bestimmte Hirnregion zuschrieb,
wissen wir heute,
dass beim kreativen Arbeiten
mehrere Netzwerke verschiedener
Hirnregionen aktiv sind.
Wenn man nach Unterschieden zwischen
Künstlern und Nicht-Künstlern schaut,
dann findet man diese Unterschiede
vor allem in den Verbindungen
zwischen den Regionen.
Galls Idee von einem Schubladen-Hirn
war viel zu einfach gedacht.
Aber vor allem
ist diese ganze Vorstellung,
Persönlichkeitseigenschaften von
der Schädelform ablesen zu wollen,
nachweislicher Murks.
Es kommt zwar vor, dass das Volumen
bestimmter Hirnregionen
tatsächlich in Verbindung steht mit
stärker ausgeprägten Eigenschaften.
Etwa findet man
bei Londoner Taxifahrern,
die einen riesigen Stadtplan
im Kopf haben,
einen größeren hinteren Hippocampus
als bei Londoner Busfahrern,
die nur ihre Routen kennen müssen.
Nur ohne einen Kernspintomografen
kann man das nicht sehen.
Also ... es sei denn,
man schneidet die Schädel
von Taxifahrern und Busfahrern auf.
Ihr werdet nicht an der Schädelform,
einen Taxifahrer erkennen.
Falls noch Zweifel bestehen,
in dieser Studie
wurde explizit analysiert:
Gibt es einen Zusammenhang
zwischen bestimmten Schädelhöckern
und bestimmen Eigenschaften, wie sie
von Gall und Co postuliert wurden?
Sind jetzt Menschen
mit ausgeprägteren Musikhöckern,
wo auch immer die liegen,
auch tatsächlich öfter Berufsmusiker?
Die Daten Tausender MRTs
wurden dazu ausgewertet.
Doch es waren keine
derartigen Zusammenhänge zu sehen.
Was nicht verwunderlich ist,
denn das zweite Studienergebnis war:
Es gibt praktisch keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen Gehirnform und Schädelform.
Diese ganze Schädellehre
die Franz Joseph Gall
"Phrenologie" nannte,
ist ganz klar
eine Pseudowissenschaft.
Und eine ziemlich gefährliche
noch dazu.
Fangen wir mit etwas
verhältnismäßig Harmlosen an.
Im 19. Jahrhundert
wurde Phrenologie angewendet,
um anhand der Kopfform treue von
untreuen Ehemännern zu unterscheiden.
Was aus heutiger Sicht
vielleicht amüsant scheint.
Aber Phrenologie
wurde in der Geschichte
leider immer wieder benutzt,
um Diskriminierung
und Menschenverachtung
wissenschaftlich zu rechtfertigen,
indem man anders aussehenden Menschen
schlechte Charaktereigenschafen
zuschrieb.
Wie etwa Schwarzen während
der Sklaverei in den USA
oder Juden im Nationalsozialismus.
Man wollte Faulheit,
Dummheit oder Boshaftigkeit
an der Kopf-
oder Gesichtsform ablesen.
Der italienische Arzt und Kriminologe
Cesare Lombroso bezog sich
auf die Phrenologie,
um vermeintlich geborenen Verbrechern
ihre kriminelle Veranlagung
am Gesicht abzulesen.
Diese biokriminologische Idee
wurde natürlich auch
von den Nazis aufgegriffen,
um ihre eigenen Verbrechen
zu rechtfertigen.
Vertrauenswürdigkeit
am Gesicht ablesen zu wollen
ist also insgesamt eine blöde Idee.
Deswegen haben
die Autoren dieser Studie
so starken Gegenwind erhalten.
Ist das wirklich,
was sie gemacht haben?
Die Technik, um die sich der
Vertrauenswürdigkeitomat dreht,
ist ein Machine-Learning-Algorithmus.
Wie funktioniert das?
Sagen wir, ich programmiere
einen Algorithmus,
der Fotos von Roborowski-Hamstern
und Pfeifhasen unterscheiden kann.
Beides sind Nagetiere, beide gehören
zu meinen Lieblingstieren.
Aber Roborowski-Hamster
sind viel kleiner,
was auf Fotos
schwierig zu erkennen ist.
Aber sie sind auch viel runder,
während Pfeifhasen
wenn sie pfeifen, sogar kurzfristig
einen Hals bekommen.
Wait for it.
Quiekendes Pfeifen)
Bei Machine-Learning füttere ich
den Algorithmus mit Datensätzen,
in denen er
nach bestimmten Mustern sucht.
Also, der Algorithmus
kann dann lernen,
dass charakteristisch
für den Roborowski-Hamstern ist,
dass er eine runde Form hat.
Nachdem er trainiert ist,
kann ich ihm ein unbekanntes Foto
geben, das kann er dann erkennen.
Allerdings kann dabei
einiges schieflaufen.
Forscher der Uni Tübingen haben etwa
einen Fischerkennungsalgorithmus
analysiert und dabei festgestellt,
dass der Algorithmus
die Fischart Schleie hieran erkennt.
(lacht:) Das sind menschliche Finger.
Weil die Schleie
ein beliebter Sportfisch ist,
und es deswegen von dem armen Fisch
sehr viele Fotos gibt,
wo er von Anglern so gehalten wird.
Sodass das
das charakteristische Merkmal wurde.
Machine-Learning
kann gut funktionieren,
aber auch in die Hose gehen.
Was war jetzt das Prinzip hinter
diesem Vertrauenswürdigkeitometer?
Die Forscher nahmen sich künstlich
hergestellte Bilder von Gesichtern,
die mal in einer anderen Studie
von verschiedenen Leuten
in ihrer Vertrauenswürdigkeit
bewertet wurden.
Diese Bilder zusammen
mit ihren Bewertungen
wurden einem Machine-Learning-
Algorithmus gefüttert,
und der sollte
bestimmte Muster erkennen.
Etwa, dass ein Lächeln
oder große Augen
als besonders vertrauenswürdig
bewertet werden.
Der trainierte Algorithmus
soll dann erkennen,
bei einem unbekannten Gesicht,
wie vertrauenswürdig dieses Gesicht
von den Teilnehmern
bewertet werden würde.
Das wendeten die Forscher nun an,
und zwar auf gemalte historische
Porträts von 1500 bis heute.
Über die der Algorithmus voraussagte,
wie vertrauenswürdig
die jeweils bewertet werden würden.
Dabei kam raus,
je neuer die Porträts,
desto höher die empfundene
Vertrauenswürdigkeit.
Laut Algorithmus.
Okay, aber was war jetzt
daran so problematisch?
Ist das jetzt Phrenologie?
Genau genommen nicht.
Denn der Algorithmus misst gar nicht,
wie vertrauenswürdig Leute sind,
sondern nur wie
vertrauenswürdig sie wirken.
Das ist ein wichtiger Unterschied.
Trotzdem ist
diese Studie problematisch.
Und zwar aus drei Gründen.
Die Frage ist,
wie gut ist dieser Algorithmus.
Also, wie gut ist er darin,
die Bewertung von Gesichtern
korrekt vorauszusagen?
Seine Voraussagekraft war:
Das klingt immer überzeugend,
aber statistisch signifikant
heißt in der Stochastik erst mal nur,
dass dieses Ergebnis
höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht zufällig war.
Dass das im Zweifelsfall
gar nicht viel bedeuten muss,
seht ihr selbst hier.
Um diese Datenwolke zu finden,
muss man ins Supplement,
den Anhang des Papers, schauen,
das wundert mich nicht.
Denn das ist leider nicht so geil.
Um sich das klarzumachen.
Gesichter, die von den Leuten mit
null, als neutral, bewertet wurden,
erhielten vom Algorithmus
eine komplette Range
von minus bis plus zwei.
Aber gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass sich dieser Algorithmus
noch verbessern könnte.
Selbst dann bleibt:
Wieso haben die Forscher diesen
Algorithmus überhaupt programmiert?
Was war die Motivation
hinter dieser Forschung?
Verkauft wird das so.
Wir können nicht
in der Zeit zurückreisen
und die Menschen von damals befragen,
aber wir können
unseren Algorithmus befragen.
Das klingt ja ganz cool.
Aber der Algorithmus gibt uns
keinen Einblick
in die Wahrnehmung von damals,
denn gefüttert ist er
mit Daten von heute.
Keine Ahnung,
ob Menschen im 16. Jahrhundert
Gesichter so bewertet hätten.
Man hätte bei dieser Studie genauso
gut Menschen heute befragen können.
Der Vorteil
von einem Algorithmus ist nicht,
irgendwie quasi zeitreisen,
sondern nur,
dass man größere Datenmengen
schneller auswerten kann.
Vorausgesetzt natürlich,
es funktioniert. (Räuspern)
Außerdem lehnen sich die Forscher
sehr weit aus dem Fenster
mit ihrer
historischen Interpretation.
Sie meinen: Dass Porträt
vertrauenswürdiger scheinen,
spiegele das wachsende Vertrauen
in der Gesellschaft,
die Demokratisierung und
den wachsenden Lebensstandard wider.
Das müsste mal von
einem Kunsthistoriker checken lassen.
Ich hätte da noch andere plausible
Interpretationsmöglichkeiten.
Es ist bekannt,
je attraktiver wir jemanden finden,
desto mehr vertrauen wir
dieser Person auch.
Diese Korrelation ist sehr stark.
So viel zu Kim Kardashians Score.
Da sich Schönheitsideale
im Laufe der Zeit ändern,
kann es sein, dass Porträts
umso mehr unserem heutigen
Schönheitsideal entsprechen,
je neuer sie sind
und deswegen auch zunehmend
vertrauenswürdiger wirken.
Mir scheint es,
als wollten die Autoren dieser Studie
eine große Story herbeischreiben,
wo eigentlich gar keine ist.
Das passt leider auch
zum dritten Punkt.
Noch mal, diese Studie betreibt
keine Phrenologie oder Physiognomik.
Der Algorithmus bewertet nicht
anhand von Gesichtern,
wie vertrauenswürdig Menschen
tatsächlich sind,
sondern nur, wie sie wirken.
Aber eben dieser wichtige Unterschied
wird im Titel und im Abstract,
in der Zusammenfassung,
nicht deutlich.
Nur, wenn man sich die Methoden
durchliest, checkt man,
dass es sich um empfundene
Vertrauenswürdigkeit handelt.
Wenn man aber nur
Titel und Abstract liest,
klingt es, als hätte man hier
einen Algorithmus programmiert,
der tatsächlich Vertrauenswürdigkeit
am Gesicht erkennt.
Klingt auch viel aufregender.
Kein Wunder, dass Zeitungen
wie "The Sun" begeistert aufspringen
und dieses Missverständnis
vermitteln.
So, wie ich
den Artikel hier verstehe,
haben die Autoren der Studie
mit "The Sun" zusammengearbeitet,
um die Celebrity-Gesichter
auszuwerten.
So lang man nur das macht,
ist alles noch spaßig.
Aber wenn man auf dem Schirm hat,
wie oft und wie böse Phrenologie
und Physiognomik benutzt wurden,
um wissenschaftlich Diskriminierungen
zu rechtfertigen,
können solche Späße
natürlich gefährlich werden,
wenn dieses Wissen
an die falschen Leute gerät.
Ich denke nicht, dass die
Wissenschaftler dieser Studie
das böse meinten,
die wollte ihre Arbeit
so gut und aufregend
wie möglich verkaufen.
Und sind dabei leider
übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Wir können bei "maiLab"
vielleicht sogar mitfühlen,
weil wir wissen, wie wichtig
und schwierig es ist,
Wissenschaft
schmackhaft zu verpacken,
damit die Leute einem zuhören.
Aber das darf nicht
auf Kosten der Korrektheit gehen.
Da muss man als Wissenschaftler
Verantwortung dafür übernehmen,
dass die Arbeit
nicht missverstanden wird.
Das Wichtigste bei Wissenschaft ist,
dass sachliche Kritik
ernst genommen wird.
So hat die Redaktion des Journals,
in dem die Studie
veröffentlicht wurde,
eine Notiz hinzugefügt:
Dass sie noch eine Auseinandersetzung
mit der Kritik veröffentlichen.
Es bleibt spannend!
Unsere Keks-Empfehlungen
gehen heute raus
an die ohnehin kekswürdigen
Kollegen von "Simplicissimus".
Die haben
ein sehr gutes Video gemacht,
in dem sie
die Corona-Berichterstattung
der "Bild" analysieren.
Für alle, die sich
für Machine-Learning
und künstliche Intelligenz
interessieren,
haben wir ein Video über
Brain-Machine-Interfaces.
Bis in zwei Wochen.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.